In 1918, there was this huge Navy ship that
was carrying 300 men.
It was headed to Baltimore and it went right
through this stretch of water called the Bermuda
Triangle.
You've maybe heard of it before.
But the ship never arrived to Baltimore.
Despite being able to, the ship never sent
out an S.O.S.
distress call.
No wreck was ever found.
300 men gone.
The Navy literally came out and said that
this disappearance was “one of the most
baffling mysteries in the annals of the Navy.”
That's an official quote.
This is just one of over 70 mysterious disappearances.
Hundreds of people vanished in this one little
stretch of water.
I wanted to know what was going on here.
So I did a big, deep dive into the Bermuda
Triangle.
And what I learned was kind of surprising.
Go ahead and check it out on my channel.